welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and black widow just reminded us
all that marvel studios used to make
movies
big movies that we can theorize on
without having our theories disproven a
week later when episode two comes out
movies with post-credits scenes that
confuse some folks into flocking to nerd
youtube
looking for answers i'm stalling because
spoiler warning if you have not yet seen
black widow
go on go watch this movie i'll be here
waiting this video is brought to you by
squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
to run your business
okay so black widow follows natasha
romanov after siding with team cap in
captain america's civil war making her a
fugitive as she rejoins her former
russian spy family including elena
alexey and melina now on a mission to
liberate all the other widows from the
mind control of drakov
in his red room along with his assassin
taskmaster
revealed to be draco's daughter whom
natasha thought she had let burned to
death a detail that was teased by
loki of all people all the way back in
the first avengers film
i got red in my ledger i'd like to wipe
it out
can you wipe out that much red drakov's
daughter but
after killing drakov destroying the red
room liberating a small group of widows
and going their separate ways two weeks
after this natasha appears with shorter
blonde hair and yelena's vest
setting her up on her future that we see
in avengers infinity war and that leads
to this movie's one post-credits scene
that is now taking place in the present
mcu era presumably the year 2024
after avengers end game with the elena
visiting natasha's grave after her
sacrifice and end game giving up her
life to get the soul stone on vermeer
elena has a dog with her
come on fanny
fanny being a callback to that alias
mason put on natasha's ids
danny longbottom now this grave is in
the midwest most likely their childhood
town in
ohio but then out of nowhere appearing
at elena's side
is valentina allegra contessa de
fontaine aka val
julia louis-dreyfus character who
appeared in episode 5 of the falcon
winter soldier
you're not supposed to be bothering me
on my holiday time valentina
okay i want to raise oh yeah you and me
both
believe me you're gonna earn it i've got
your next target
maybe you'd like a shot at the man
responsible
for your sister's death
oh my god an ipad mini i thought apple
products were only for the good guys
which side is everybody on
so in the comics valentina allegra
contessa de fontaine is a shield agent
companion to nick fury
she did a brief stint as madame hydra
and was impersonated by skrull at the
start of secret invasion in the falcon
and the winter soldier she approached a
recently discharged john walker after
his public execution of a flag smasher
she told him he did the right thing that
the politicians don't understand
and that she knew that he took the super
soldier serum something he hadn't really
told anyone else
and that captain america's shield didn't
belong to the government but was in a
quote legal grey area and then in the
next episode the finale val
said things were quote about to get
weird then suits of john walker as
u.s agent completing his transition into
the short-tempered murica assassin from
the comics but based on all this the mcu
vowel
seems partly based on the character
victoria hand from the comics
someone who also showed up in agents of
shield in the comics she assisted norman
osborne during
the dark rain era in the oversight of a
team called the thunderbolts that was a
group of anti-hero
assassins which is actually later led by
u.s agent john walker but rather than
her working with norman osborne or even
nick fury who seems too busy looking for
his shoes in space
i believe val's silent partner is
thaddeus thunderbolt ross who appeared
at the beginning and the end of black
widow in hot pursuit of natasha the mcu
thunderbolts might take his name and be
made of assassins with clouded morality
overtaking lives including john walker
and now
elena belova since she has been working
for valve for some time by the way
based on the latest shang chi trailer i
think emil blonsky abomination is also
part of this lineup
additional doses of the super soldier
serum from the power broker in madripore
supplied by his old handler thaddeus
ross maybe one of the power broker
sharon carter's contacts
could have changed his appearance from
the 2008 look to the greener more comic
accurate look
and maybe val and ross are forcing
abomination to compete in the tin rings
fighting tournament so that they get a
chance at getting their hands on that
mystical tech and we know ross is still
involved with enhanced humans based on
that clue in the falcon winter soldier
credits that listed his name
and his involvement with the enhanced
humans act so as you can tell i'm
obsessed with breaking down the missible
details of my favorite shows and movies
maybe you are obsessed with
groot fan art or ancient architecture
recreated with tropical fruit and you
need a website to share your passion
with the world well squarespace
is the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence and let the
world see your leaning tower of papaya
pisa squarespace lets you present
members only gated content
connect your social media accounts
present video content and all the other
cool features to give you a
super cool super functional website for
your hobby or your business
you can collect the emails of fellow
pineapple parthenon enthusiasts
and send custom newsletters squarespace
will even
sell you a url so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
new rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com
newrockstars for 10 off your first
purchase of a website or
domain now other members of this
thunderbolts lineup i suspect could be
zemo currently being held in ross's raft
prison
and maybe even ag of the harkness
because why not have an avenger hating
sorceress on your team
but why are val and elena targeting
hawkeye well florence pugh was reported
to join the hawkeye cast around when
kevin feige talked about the show last
december but other than that no major
announcement or even a trailer for the
series has been released and now it
seems like marvel has been waiting for
black widow to come
out in this photo clint barton is in his
assassin attire
suggesting that this was taken around
when he was going rogue killing
criminals in tokyo in avengers in-game
i'm guessing that as one of the few og
avengers left on earth in operation
clint barton might not want to play ball
with val's plans or may even be working
against her recruitment of assassins and
now he knows too much and needs to be
taken out
it's also possible that by target they
could just be talking about some
attempts to recruit him no
i just think it is odd that val blames
clint for natasha's death not just
because it's wrong natasha let herself
go against clint's wishes but because it
tells us that val
knows about the inner workings of the
avengers time heist mission something i
don't think is public knowledge based on
that vague verbiage about the time heist
and cap's smithsonian exhibit in the
falcon the winter soldier so we gotta
wonder who val's sources
are did she flip someone in the avengers
did bruce banner or peter parker spill
the beans
or something or does val have some
powers we don't know about because again
she blips up right beside elena seconds
after a wide shot showed
no one else in sight she could be using
some cloaking tech like what we've seen
nick fury use in the comics specifically
when he was trailing val
to figure out that she was being
impersonated by scroll or go with me on
this
could she have appeared from atva time
door and when you flip that tda logo
upside down you get
oh my god i know it's a reach i will
admit but we still don't know what val
meant by things are about to get weird
and that shield being a legal gray area
especially if you consider that old
steve might have come from a branch
timeline and on loki the tva might have
considered that cap a variant who might
have had to negotiate some very specific
legal terms
to make that in-game cameo thus perhaps
the legal gray area val described
and if val is possibly connected to the
tva yes that would be very weird
let me know what you think of this scene
and what you thought of black widow
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options including this loki
inspired shirt loki out of time at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter
eaboss and if you're interested in my
breakdowns of everything marvel be sure
to subscribe to new rockstars we got you
covered here thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you